CHANYOUNG PARK: My film shoot was
a really magical experience
because my crew actually ended up becoming
this mini version of my film, in real life.
ALEX FORD: The more you experience,
the more stories you can tell ...
so why restrict yourself because you might
get a little bit less sleep at night?
EMMA MICHALAK: That's what I think
is the greatest thing about film.
It gets you to be more in touch with
the deepest, most human parts of yourself.
I came to Princeton and jumped into
studying literature and the arts.
CHANYOUNG PARK: I changed my major about
four times, until I settled on film production.
ALEX FORD: I actually came
into Princeton being pre-med.
CHANYOUNG PARK: I was studying French
and I ultimately went abroad.
ALEX FORD: There was a snowstorm
for a week, and I didn't leave my room
and I watched 21 movies in 5 days.
CHANYOUNG PARK: I literally went
to the movie theater every single day,
sometimes three times a day
if I was feeling a little crazy.
EMMA MICHALAK: I've taken everything from
poetry to fiction to screenwriting.
ALEX FORD: I watched "12 Years a Slave,"
then right after that
I watched "How to Train Your Dragon."
EMMA MICHALAK: That intersection of all
those mediums informed the way I've developed
as a creative artist and filmmaker
and screenwriter and actor.
CHANYOUNG PARK: I really developed
this relationship with films.
ALEX FORD: I think I want to do this for real,
I think I actually want to be a filmmaker.
CHANYOUNG PARK: I took a class with
P. Adams Sitney and really loved him
because he just didn't care about anything
but was totally brilliant, and actually
he was the first person who
taught me how to "read" film
as an art medium,
not as a content device.
EMMA MICHALAK: I was fortunate enough to
get paired with Professor Christina Lazaridi
who I am now thrilled to call a mentor
and I would even say, a friend.
She's wonderful,
she's a creative genius.
ALEX FORD: I've been pretty close
to Su since my sophomore year.
She's been my adviser every year.
She's somebody who's actually made me
believe a lot in myself,
and she said, "The reason I'm hard on you
about things is because I believe that
you can actually be a great filmmaker."
So I started applying to internships
and all of a sudden I ended up getting
an internship at Dreamworks,
That kind of just fell out of the sky, and
I worked there every summer since.
EMMA MICHALAK: I got an email that
Terrence Malick was coming to visit campus.
I went to the screening that he did a
brief talk afterwards.
I kind of overheard that there
was going to be a lunch,
and we just talked to Terrence Malick
for a little bit over lunch,
and I got an email shortly afterwards
that went a little something like,
"You may have talked your way into a job
with Terrence Malick."
I'm going to be down in Austin at his
production outfit, working
in the editorial department on Radegund,
which is his upcoming feature film.
[Singing in French]
CHANYOUNG PARK: My thesis film is a short comedy
that I shot in the south of France this past summer
based off of my friend, an American student
who is half Vietnamese and half French
who has this really ambiguous
racial appearance.
As a Korean international student,
I totally feel that hybridity
is becoming more and more relevant
to today's society so
that's why I chose to tell this topic in a comic
form, but nonetheless with a lot of pathos.
ALEX FORD: So I went to Haiti with my dad
after the earthquake that happened in 2010.
He's a doctor, so he went
to do some operations.
It was against my will, because I was
kind of a spoiled brat back then
but going there was probably one of the
most life-changing experiences I've ever had.
I worked in a medical warehouse.
I met somebody named Madness,
and he and I bonded.
That's really what the film is about.
It's about this friendship.
It's about this belief in dreams.
EMMA MICHALAK: My thesis is called "In the Garden,"
and it is a feature-length screenplay.
I wrote 30-35 pages and then completely
scrapped it because I did not like the idea.
So then I thought about what's in a name,
and what it means to be named Eve.
My screenplay is about three
women around the world
who are each named
iterations of "Eve."
CHANYOUNG PARK: No one should be able
to shoot a 25-minute film in three days,
in their third language, in a foreign country
where you know, like, 10 people max.
ALEX FORD: So I went to Haiti last June.
I held auditions there.
I got the script translated into Haitian Creole,
I worked with some Haitian producers.
Everything was held in a foreign language.
It was a really difficult journey
of communication
CHANYOUNG PARK: When we shot the last scene ever
for our film I had a moment of complete breakdown.
I went over to a corner in the garage
and I just started crying
because I was so tired.
All this gratitude hit me at once.
My host mother, my professor, my two teachers,
they were all hugging me,
just kissing me everywhere, and telling me
how proud they are of me,
how they admired the process, and all that.
That will always remain
such a poetic moment for me.
EMMA MICHALAK: In an ideal world,
I would like to have it produced.
I'm not sure whether I would be
directing it, or in it.
I'm hoping over the next couple
of years to get funding for it,
and get it realized -- get it made into
the feature film that it is.
STUDENT 1: It was awesome, I was so happy
to be here for the first screening!
STUDENT 2: My main man!
ALEX FORD: I'm very excited to tell
my stories, and I think that the best way
for me to do so
is to write and direct.
CHANYOUNG PARK: I've found my life passion,
at least for now, which is filmmaking
so I want to continue
after graduation.